[Music]
in inseparable news submitted by love
from Poland no conjoined twins refused a
life-saving surgery despite doctors
warnings oh how old are they want to
stay together they want yeah I can see
that your whole life you've only known
it one way that could be really scary I
would love the view all right
yeah I think someone like me though like
my personality I need to have my
dependence for this because you know
you're independent
yeah usually we're in this trust if you
never knew what that felt led you but
then someone like my little sister who
also tastes and she hated it she likes
being with someone yeah always has to be
connected to someone
mm-hmm how are they physically connected
yeah she has a picture what they look
like and how different are they this is
so good I know my face too cause like if
me and Nikki were conjoined it's like
I'd be like I want Mexican food and
she'd be like lots of my stomach like
crazy
and you like I don't eat sushi Nami I
don't want to do they share weight how
many legs do they have they have one
like each that's why oh no wonder if you
yeah if you split then you're just gonna
have less and you have half a vagina did
I say that more authority three arms oh
they each have two arms to this forearm
okay cool yeah but I wouldn't want just
one leg and you have like one fallopian
tube and then like as your uterus split
in half how does that work if they do
that it is not two sets of organs this
is a shared body part they share their
legs so we have one they share some ribs
their circulatory systems their
digestive system and the reproductive
system they share all that
yeah and then the separate body part is
their arms heart lungs and stomach
their names are Carmen and Lupita
they're both 16 they're born in Mexico
but now live in Connecticut so they came
over on a medical visa when they were
born they were only expected to survive
for only three days another 16 oh it's
like when was your first time with the
boys
our first time with the boy was you know
I mean like that's so weird being ask me
drunk yeah with that lucky but they have
one vagina yeah one vagina one uterus
for boobs for boob I don't know
before booze I could think yeah I could
figure some job feel like that was it
like if they say together and have the
reproductive system they could have be
pregnant together like have one they
have one right well yeah the only at one
what's life-threatening about staying
together so Lupita she has goalie OSes
and it's cramping her lungs oh she needs
to have part of her spine removed but
it's a super risky surgery honestly
because there's not a lot of doctors
that have had a lot of experience
performing surgery on conjoined twins
are so few of them but they're saying
that they could die or suffer brain
damage but the twins are refusing the
surgery they said quote there's a lot
more risk to it and it actually being
beneficial so we decided not to which is
going to live out life and that's it
that makes sense that's why I like it oh
so it's not like a split surgery it's
just a it's just a little spying work
yeah it actually can't be separated
because of how many organizations there
and the circulatory system and so
they're just like if we if we just die
so if one dies does the other one die
because they have separate hearts and
lungs no one dies and the case like this
they would body bag one half of the body
there's nothing like how to be use that
I guess what it cuz it's a scoliosis
girls eyes water lung collapses or
whatever like the other girl has or her
own set of lungs and heart sorry
I just love it if terrible pain because
that's how it was hotties well your say
hello say I'm just curious about who
controls the leg so it's pretty
interesting so the one on the right
controls the left leg oh yeah all could
you Brandon that's right that way right
yeah well I think it's all sort of the
way or yeah probably but it's also kind
of like the way you got the off side no
it's tiring
yeah yeah I kind of look like they're
buddies where it would be formed this
way and that way but they're like
scissors I feel like give those Beyonce
she would take a picture then she
getting her cartridge like well that was
crazy like [ __ ] like that you know
thanks Linda no turbines with gingers
people Tyra Banks is an angel
beyond security they're so pretty just
photos of their lives
that's a quinceanera yeah possibly it's
kind of cool because they both look like
they're doing this true they're in that
position you're so happy I love it yeah
they're super sweet girls I just gotta
find a guy who wants to be with two
chicks the same try to make Bank Lou
honey yeah I think it does get the by
skew of one and then just show it to do
this Oh cute look at they're just
hugging all the time
are they doing yoga are they like their
agent like they find out if you're on
excuse no they're doing garden work
right yeah the great ironing work you
guys laughs you're terrible beep how can
I keep going
so can the other one control like do
they both have control over like certain
body parts because that'll be crazy like
if they get in a fight and then they
both can control the arm and then it's
like no but it's the same arm no I have
their they have their arms I would love
to be the aggressor of that fight like
why would you fight you Siamese twins
whatever they do this no but I think
it's whoever's brain as the spinal cord
is connected to the Leland Jarrett
that's the thing it'll sure it's not a
party and they don't share are going to
be cool to share it not wouldn't be cool
that's true you're like so inefficient
Calipari's trying to do one thing and
you're trying to do another thing yeah
you're like doing something right now or
whatever you're like drinking or
whatever and then all the sudden your
arm does some other [ __ ] like you're to
Jim Carrey movie and say hey that's not
what I wanted to do yeah all the foot
you know what's crazy that also means
like if you hit the arm of one of the
girls only one of the girls feels it
yeah because I was curious about like
how one girl controls one leg like if
something happens to that leg there's
only one girl feel no the other girl
won't be able to feel it
I'm just so hearing about like if one
died there's another one say lies Larry
I don't think they can I guess like a
heart would stop and then the blood
would corrode well yeah cause do they
share organs no they don't share every
system oh they don't share a heart or
lungs so you
don't but the stomach shakily in a
bikini yeah they share that do they can
do some but like could one person's
heart and lungs contribute enough to
sustain the other body parts what I do
say because of the one that has
scoliosis and her lungs are being
constricted the other one has to breathe
extra hard to to make up for it suggest
I work together Matt but on the bright
side they could pull off some pretty
unique Halloween costumes yeah which is
really pretty we have in mind it could
be a spider they could be what I don't
know like we've got a caramel and Gretel
or some [ __ ] what is just couple or no
no salt and pepper right Soulpepper no
what's that one where they got the baby
on the back laughing oh you see that one
where it looks like you got it's like
you look you're you're a person right
and then you have a baby on your back
they could do some [ __ ] like that
oh-ho like that yeah and they would have
a third head person riding a dinosaur
they could be a headless horseman they
could do a lot of things that we can't
do a lot of cool [ __ ]
yeah there's normal teenage girls but
there's one that couldn't be able to
control one leg right mm-hmm
that's crazy cuz then so have you ever
played that like race at the park at a
potluck or whatever where you do this
and then you tie the leg and yes it's
all round that's hard so they have to
sync the balance and like I think we're
up doing this 15 years apart but that's
still difficult I can still be an eraser
I bet it's hard for you pulling off to
them it's like second nature
yeah they took the first steps once when
they were 4 years old I took them a
while them for you usually start Patti a
gear and a little bit less in yet or
locking house crazy and I started at six
months and that's why I'm pigeon-toed
and then that develops scoliosis maybe
six months early early early it's super
early like my bones hadn't even fully
formed yet so the only way I could
balance was by either going all the way
out with my feet or all the way in so as
I went all the way in and then the bones
hardened more like with my feet turned
in and that's like all the way at the
hip and then a [ __ ] up the way I
walked my whole life so then my spine
got all [ __ ] and weird and then like
now I have Scalia
- and I'm just almost on my back hurts
all the time so if I see my smile
starting to watch 16 foam kiss triple
yeah yeah take them in ankles and make
them fall oh I was in a hurry to do
everything in life like I want to walk
as fast as I could I wanted to read as
fast as I could I wanted to come on baby
sit down you have an orthopaedic shoes
your will we use those now right now
yeah they don't look a little bit uglier
Victor and I got home most of my life
right now yeah but I'll see it I don't
want to yeah yeah nobody wants to I want
to be in good cool shoes at home yeah
stilettos all the time none of that
[ __ ] boots [ __ ] or whatever you give
him a mom like a two different doctors
and they both said I should be fine with
him happen when I was like 2 where she
could have fixed it they wanted Derek
and general twin doctors just was one
visit and both doctors were like yeah
now you're probably good well I think
you should get a second opinion not just
a second opinion so she because she
thought she got a second opinion second
visit but the second visit a whole
different doctor cousin option is you
know what's up I kept on long [ __ ] up
her whole back
thanks a lot signing swimming people why
do you think I have such a hard-on for
them bit in a bad way
hard-on in a bad day yet the wait looks
like a hard-on is like in the term of
like is like a like a pays off like a
hey babe don't say that you know about a
16 year old was it what's - oh there was
a hot conjoined twins was it the the
hotel American Horror Story
right those conjoined twins right the
circus ones I would totally smash hey
guys I hope you enjoyed that episode of
just kidding News and if you guys want
to share a story there's a link down in
the description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
[Music]